hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen I'm Justine and we are
getting ready for the holidays by making
some simple easy treats at this point I
don't know if I've actually made one
that's successful yet but that's okay
just keep trying
try again I think that this is gonna be
pretty successful because I've already
pre-made the brownies so my hope is that
if this doesn't come out of here
we'll be able to salvage this and make
it work but I think it will I made this
last night so we could make this video
and get things done let's see what
happens ready please please please
please please yes hallelujah
well brownie is good this should be
pretty easy so make yourself a brownie
inside of a round pan and then you're
gonna cut it into triangles oh that's
great cook through like that
cool so we're going to make little
Christmas trees so for this you're going
to need to make yourself the brownie
you're gonna need some green icing and
sprinkles and some candy canes I got
these on Amazon Amazon Prime they came
the next day so once you've got your
little brownies here all in your little
triangles I'm going to find the best
ones I'm gonna place come on these
plates right here and we'll decorate I'm
just thinking about portion sizes this
is probably like four brownies in one
seam out I got them a little bit smaller
but that's up to you so I got these but
you can also get bigger ones if you
decide to make your portion size massive
let's pick out three of these little
guys so just going to stick it in the
bottom of your Brownton
you might need to drill a hole mistakes
were made
just stick that on she's freaking dumb
three cool I was real hole over here boy
do I love the holidays
I love holiday baking I actually like
when other people holiday bake that's
usually edible let's put you in here oh
those look so good now you just want to
decorate it however you see fit to make
it look like a tree a lot I'm not strong
enough I'm not strong enough to make the
whole tree Buddy Holly Jolly Christmas
that one looks good
that was a discount tree we got that one
on sale I'm gonna make this one you go
like this you really can do whatever you
want
oh shoot so maybe I'll just keep with
that same theme you'll just know here's
the best part about baking and all
usually tastes the same it might not
look good but okay
dad your sprinkles all those looks so
pretty
mmm they're all bad I think they look
quite good thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed my wonderful
little simple treats this is a brownie
Christmas tree if you can't tell if you
missed the introduction to this video
that's what we just made
let me know if you guys decide to make
this be sure to send me a tweet or an
Instagram or Facebook or however it is
that you guys communicate on the
internet these days
feel free to send me your masterpieces
and see if you can make it better than I
did it
oh geez
kidnapped you're breaking my arm
[Music]
you